the nba finals tip off tonight between
the boston celtics and the golden state
warriors and in honor of that we are
bringing you a new installment of our
series note to self featuring a familiar
voice to millions of basketball fans
inside the nba host ernie johnson has
been covering the league for more than
three decades behind the scenes he's a
father of six and has faced a series of
health issues over the years himself in
this note to his younger self johnson
reflects on his challenges including the
heartbreak of losing his adopted son
dear freshman
you're living the dream right now aren't
you
there you stand in 1975 wearing the
uniform of the georgia bulldogs
it's what the johnson family calls a
blackberry moment
goes back to that little league team you
were on when two of your teammates
stopped looking for a ball that had
bounced over the fence and ate
blackberries instead
sweet moments to savor
those are blackberry moments and you're
living one right now playing college
ball and wearing number 32 the same one
your dad wore when he played in the big
leagues you're wondering if you have the
same talents that took him to the majors
sorry kid
you don't
you'll be cut the next year
and then like most college kids you'll
be trying to figure out what on earth
you're gonna do with your life you're
really not thinking much about a career
in broadcasting though you've been
around it most of your life and your dad
was really good at it
here's a [ __ ]
[Applause]
[Music]
that's the career you'll pursue from
radio stations in athens everybody knows
it's tough to keep cool during this heat
wave to reporting the news on tv in
macon georgia and spartanburg south
carolina and atlanta what does my father
think ask him right here what do you
think where you'll transition from news
into sports let's go to ernie johnson at
the palace ernie thank you very much
craig
the call from turner broadcasting will
change your life the bulls are halfway
through their regular season schedule
now you'll have the chance to cover
every sport you can think of it'll be
something you refer to as a get to job
not a got to job
and along the way you'll work with your
dad nothing will ever match that ernie
johnson in our atlanta studio not even
the decades of work hosting inside the
nba for more than 30 years
you don't know these names yet but
charles barkley shaquille o'neal and
kenny smith
won't just be your partners on that show
they will be your brothers for life
you grew up with parents who instilled
in you the values of hard work
determination resolve love respect and
faith
those will carry you through that career
i just outlined
but keep this in mind
your job is what you do
it's not who you are
covering the newsbeat you'll meet a bank
teller named cheryl deluca she's working
her way through college at mercer and
macon and every week she cashes your
paychecks which aren't much
cheryl will tell folks for years that
you guys met through six inches of
bulletproof glass
you will see through that window into a
soul older than yours and an intellect
that dwarfs yours
but for some reason three years after
you meet she'll say yes to the idea of
marrying you and you'll wonder if her
response was rooted in pity or if it was
love
i'll choose love
always choose love it never fails
[Music]
before too long you two will become
parents a little boy you'll name eric
and a daughter maggie
as a man you'll feel i don't know
complete
but let me throw you a little curveball
which i know you were never very good at
hitting
don't be afraid to go unscripted you'll
learn that from cheryl
you're a sportscaster she's a world
changer
a baptism of orphans in bucharest a
hospital nursery filled with unwanted
romanian babies a news story about
abandoned romanian orphans prompts her
to suggest something unscripted
adopting one of those kids
in the summer of 1991 you will stay home
with eric and maggie while your wife
travels to romania
a little boy nearly three years old is
brought out to her his name is orrell
mihi
he can't walk he can't talk he's
malnourished
cheryl is told by the woman who handed
him to her
don't take this boy he's no good
[Music]
your wife will call you from bucharest
and describe the child and offer this
he's so much more than we can handle but
i can't imagine living the rest of my
life wondering whatever happened to that
blond-haired boy in the orphanage
and in that moment because you know that
in the tone of her voice you are getting
a glorious look into the depth of her
soul
you will say four words well
bring him home
two years later you'll travel to
paraguay where a perfectly healthy
little girl is waiting carmen will
become the most recent addition to the
johnson family but not the last years
later you will meet allison and ashley
half sisters who would never really
known a permanent home and you'll give
them one
it would be nice to end this letter
right here with
and they lived happily ever after
our stories can all have fairy tale
chapters but there are just as many
which deal with real life challenges and
heartbreak and disappointments far
greater than being cut by the college
baseball team
on two occasions 16 years apart you'll
sit in a doctor's office and be told you
have cancer
the words will shake you to your core
but don't panic
you'll take to heart what one of the
technicians told you as you were having
your body scanned you may have cancer
but it doesn't have you
three words will become your personal
mantra trust god
period
medicine and surgery will fix you
but it's your faith your family and your
friends who will sustain you
[Music]
you'll lose your dad
a guy who taught you everything you
needed to know about being a man a
husband a father
the guy whose basic career advice was to
be yourself and to always take the high
road
he'll be the best man at your wedding
you'll give him a pewter beer mug
engraved my best man my best friend
years later your son eric will ask you
to be his best man
and he'll gift you in the same way
the power of that father's son bond
it'll bring you to your knees
oh and that little boy you adopt from
romania michael
you'll find out a year after you bring
him home that he has duchenne muscular
dystrophy
there's no cure for that his muscles
won't develop they'll just continue to
weaken
he won't speak until he's eight years
old
his favorite thing to say will be
love you too
[Music]
and it will become your family's calling
card
you'll be amazed at how his spirit just
draws people to him
he will defy the odds by living 33
blackberry filled years
and while you and your family will shed
a torrent of tears at his passing
you will all unabashedly dance
[Applause]
to one of his favorite songs
family
[Music]
as you celebrate his life
and that's where i'll wrap it up
freshman
family
the one you were born into set the bar
incredibly high
be intentional about trying to meet that
standard
it'll give your life purpose
and value and a glimpse of the divine
oh and by the way that number 32
just wait till you see your
grandchildren wearing it at the little
league fields
talk about your blackberry moments
[Music]
love you too
ernie
[Music]
oh man ernie johnson where are the
tissues maybe we all have a life full of
blackberry moments i love it's so
beautifully told his life story you
never know what's going on in people's
lives right i had no idea ernie johnson
still has that amazing voice yes that he
had from the time that he was a little
kid he's writing so many layers to that
so many layers you're writing to your
college freshman self you know i
remember being a college freshman so
nervous about how your life's gonna turn
out the highs and the lows i mean the
richness of that life
includes everything yeah i've heard for
so long that ernie is an individual that
lives for other people yeah you see that
i have an example of that i hope he
doesn't mind me reading this i don't
know where i get a text a handful of
months ago just wanted to reach out and
tell you you're killing it on the
morning show it goes without saying that
you've excelled on the nfl show but my
wife and i both love the work that
you're doing monday through friday i
know that was a big transition and
you've made it look effortless ej with
the emoji yeah
and uh i almost cried because i'm such a
huge fan he didn't need to do that yeah
um he doesn't need to do a lot of things
that's what makes him special he says
always choose love ernie johnson sending
you big love and ben rosenthal who
produced that ben rosenthal by the way
is one of the producers it's his first
note to self you go ben craig shea one
of the best editors worked with him many
times bravo bravo bravo very well done
thank you very much